[Music]
hamilton
this has nothing to do with the play i
imagine or the musical what is it i've i
haven't seen it
like saying cut that out no one should
know that i haven't snaked he's so mad
at me for some reason i don't know
whatever i'm not seeing it because i
it's not that i don't like it i just
haven't bothered with it just uh don't
bother me hamilton let's all
collectively get over it hamilton
[Music]
it's been three weeks since my best
friend disappeared she went to hamilton
forest with her boyfriend that's why
it's hamilton hamilton forest
and nobody has heard from them since the
police say they performed a search of
the area and found nothing
they said that further exploration was
too dangerous and that the risk to the
search party was too
great i can't imagine how you must feel
the officer had told me
his blank gaze failed to meet my eyes
but you can't go looking for them
proved you wrong here i go when i woke
up this morning a moldy page was lying
on the living room for
a set of coordinates written in what i
immediately recognized as her
handwriting you know
i would never be able to recognize my
friends handwriting
amy's handwriting i would never be able
to recognize
anyone's handwriting i don't know how
the hell you would do that unless you're
writing
letters to each other every day and then
you're super romantic and i don't do
that
this is dead a winner but i don't care i
need to know what happened
it is the dead of winter ah my mouse
sensitivity
hello hello hello
uh how are you how are you
alexander just add an echo how are
i'm an idiot i'm i'm an idiot this looks
like her backpack i must be getting
close
all right cool now with these types of
style horror games you don't know if
it's going to be
absolutely terrifying or ridiculous and
silly and not scary at all
i'm gonna go with the idea that it's
probably going to be absolutely
terrifying
okay warning too bad you put up a sign
cause i can't read
what is it boots are these her boots why
would she have taken them off in this
cold
oh no her shoes fell off she's
definitely dead
i love points of no return flump
is that blood
looks like blood i have nothing to say
about it could be cranberry juice i
guess
if we're gonna be stupid ah funny about
this sign too i
also can't read this sign so shut up
and go away
her diary looks more or less intact
maybe there's a clue inside
i got this really strange email today
about this old place in hamilton forest
apparently is super haunted due to some
crazy dark
[ __ ] that happened there years ago not
too sure if it's legit so i'll bring
jake along just in case
cops are always super strict about
staying out of hamilton so who knows
might be something cool or might be
something crazy
dark [ __ ] the next page is porn her
handwriting is barely legible i can't
even recognize it
shaky and spaced unevenly like she was
writing with her eyes closed it's going
to be great a really strange haunted
sure if it's legit but might be
something cool bring jake staying
who's this jake who is jake
huh i don't even know her name
caution
[Laughter]
well i'm in luck because i can't read
what is this that i'm looking at here
this is a face i can't tell what that is
write in the comments if you know what
that was oh good
i love winter cave door
this is a good thing oh
oh yeah you know how i said that this
might actually be terrifying yeah i got
a funny feeling it's going to be
horrifying
i thought that pipe was a person hi hey
reception i'm checking in to whatever
the hell this
is hey how you doing oh
oh yay please report any unusual or
anomalous activity immediately
our lives may depend on it yeah
i'm detecting some anomalous stuff
you know even if it was like my best
friend i don't know if i could say i'd
go into a place like this
looking for them
hi how are you mostly just because uh
well i mean [ __ ] the [ __ ] this place
there's a skull that's never good it's
not a science lab there's not gonna be
skulls laying around
that ain't a thing that do it's almost
impossible to completely restrict entry
into the exclusion zone
simply because it covers too big of an
area which borders multiple towns in the
region
people wandering all the time and the
amount of missing persons reflect that
providing extensive warnings about some
fake dangers that's proven to be
ineffective given they don't usually
dissuade the foolhardy it's hard to lie
to families about why the police can't
send search parties out to look for
their loved ones
it's harder to stop them from doing it
themselves yummy
me are you talking about me
am i one of those foolhardies now i'm
i'm the one that's going to survive
no i'm better than all those idiots that
came before me and died
now i'm the smart one i'm sorry my spit
i'm the one that is good at the
surviving
hey allison ally ali
al whatever your name is was
is
i'd recognize that chair scraping
anywhere
that's my best friend's butt in a chair
scraping across the ground
i'd know my best friend's butt anywhere
oh yeah them's ally's cheeks all right
we're fine upon entering the exclusion
zone individuals are immediately at risk
though the evidence suggests that the
chance of them being affected
by the phenomenon is linked to their
distance from what is currently thought
to be the center-most point of the
exclusion
zone satellite imagery shows that this
area contains and as of yet
explored cavern located within the east
region of hamilton forest all attempts
to reach the cavern have been
met with failure i don't know if i was
emphasizing the right words there oh
yeah this is
this is good whatever it is i'm looking
at here is this a vending machine
give me a snack i'm hungry all right
[Music]
i'm not sure if that was al's cheeks oh
yeah is my flashlight on it really
doesn't seem to be working like
flashlights usually do
you know how they are a beam of light
that casts light not just a weird
bubble of light around me what am i
looking at what am i looking at what am
i seeing in front of me what am i seeing
in front of me what am i seeing what is
that what are you
what is that zoom
oh we are okay please send emergency
assistance
i hate that i hate that hf admin has set
status of hmms facility to critical
incoming communication
okay please verify report massive
internal event has occurred
admin o1 disappeared during onset of
event tracker reporting as
out of range time limited please tell us
everything you can
started with massive power loss
automated backup generator activated
blade
mass personnel disappearance cree
are you okay please respond we are okay
please send emergency assistance
we are unable to do that while the
facility is created
okay please re-enter your verification
code verification go to protect
center hq is activated workstation
camera hmm
i don't like that i don't like that
and i don't like that i don't like the
tube sticking out of your neck i don't
like anything about
that that's awful hate that i'm giving
you this letter in confidence as i don't
want to incite a
paranoid but this is urgent the most
recent occurrence
forced forces to re-evaluate the
estimated outermost perimeter of the
exclusion zone
assuming as we have been that the zone
is a perfect circle our new data
suggests that the hamilton forest
monitoring station lies within the
bounds of the exclusion zone i am forced
to conclude
that the only reason we have not yet
been affected by the phenomena is that
the station lies so close to the edge
that the probability of an event
occurring is extremely low
please be reminded that i cannot provide
any information that indicates what the
chances exactly
are as we still do not know the
potential triggers and have not been
able to find any meaningful patterns or
indicators which would inform us of an
imminent evan aside the from the
proximity i'm proposing an immediate
evacuation under the guise of the
writing stops abruptly there's an old
polaroid photo lying next to the letter
well that's weird i'm gonna go that's
real weird
i shouldn't be here in case any was
wondering in case anyone was thunkling
i shouldn't be here oh no thank you
oh hey bud how are you doing ow
nah i'd recognize your blood anywhere
if i if i
thank you big priest
everyone preach up everyone preach
big british
enhance zoom oh
no hi is that you al
ow oh god it's her i'd recognize her
skull
and empty eye socket anywhere
okay all right if this is gonna be the
end i wanna say some last words
i and my huge dick
doth grant all my
possessions
to chica who will
oh hell's gone what the hell
what the hell
who will carry on the channel in my name
subscribers will obviously skyrocket
please she can take over the channel oh
god stop for chica oh
it didn't take long for the authorities
to figure out where you had gone
mysterious clues supposedly left by
those who had perished in the exclusion
zone had led many to meet the same fates
rescue attempts were pointless i'm dead
i really like that the police would say
you perished in a car accident while
searching for your friends your body
burned beyond recognition your story
ends here
yeah you know uh that's fair is there
multiple endings to this
i don't think so i bet not i bet not
this is fantastic i really like this
obviously simplistic style but i've
never counted simplistic style against
actual scare that's terrifying love that
love that big smooch is up
everyone smooch up this is
between these walls controls
easy play i don't know what's between
the walls
besides like insulation and wiring
[Applause]
okay well that was that was good oh
do we have a metal head we need to read
a letter
hello son your father and i are pretty
furious about the way you left us at
your previous apartment
you disappeared so fast what happened
are you still having your hallucinations
also we couldn't join you by phone so
your father suggested i wrote you a
letter
i know you and i know you're fine but
god why are you always so theatrical you
should have warned us you know
we had to find your dress ourselves now
please contact us as soon as possible
we will not run after you yes and by the
way why are there still so much
cardboard boxes in the old apartment the
place is filled with these
well i don't know i don't know why i ran
away i don't know anything about
anything
there's also wait isn't that this
apartment no it's not this part
why why why just
why well that's not right who hangs up
their towel
on the mirror someone just doesn't want
to look at their own reflection probably
okay well this place sucks alright
trying to leave i guess
i'm just an apartment hopper
hello
sorry just trying to break in oh i
thought that was an apartment
i don't know why i didn't think that all
right
i'll go up this
okay apparently no other place opens in
[Music]
this
okay fascinating
that's kind of cool i don't know what
that means but it's kind of cool
i'll go downies i'll go downy stairs
i'll go down the downy stairs oh hello
radio
well that's a little weird rc
i don't know what rc means remote
control i guess but
what else could it possibly mean such an
exhausting day time to go home
wasn't i just home oh i just went to
work
oh hello
negative one yeah that's uh that's
normal
okay don't know what rc means put in the
comments
if you know what rc means cause i sure
don't
oh it's a pull i just always slam the
door into my
what the hell i didn't see whoa hey
didn't see you i'm coming for you
i hate it what is it oh this is
disturbing
it's nothing it was just my imagination
a whole lot of nothing
that's a whole lot of nothing god if you
there's something just terrifying about
you walking in it's just there
and the box is where are we oh
whatever i'm exhausted i should go to
sleep yeah oh
yeah oh yeah
just want to make sure i didn't do that
let me leave my door open you know
i'll just go right to snooze
we snore we snow we snow
ah yeah we snow we snow well that's
we snow
what is that we snow seems like there's
something behind the door
we snow we snow
louise no we stall
we snow we snow we snow a good thing you
can't get it i hate you
i hate you also what's up with my whole
apartment not having any walls
hmm well time to go back to bed
i don't need to worry about that ah
huh shush shusham's huh
well that's a thing
okay i have no commentary on whatever
that
is time to go to work
[Music]
i bet this thing followed me why do you
made this thing oh suddenly you're now
acknowledging this thing huh you bet
this thing followed you what is what
what do you mean what do you what you
what do you mean what do you mean by
that
what do you mean you want to explain
your feelings you want to expand upon
that a little bit you want to get a
little more
detail into what you're saying i'm here
now
more boxes it's the box demon
it's the box ghost all right
[Applause]
um i'm a little goo oh wherever you go
i'll always be there with you
oh it's a different apartment slightly
the kitchen is different well that's
strange
hey mom dad having a bit of an issue
having an issue oh boy
i've got to stop buying boxes
i'm starting to think i got a problem i
just can't stop my compulsive box buying
it's literally the only thing i ever
want to do
oh i'm now in my bed
not the boxes
oh oh that's not good
oh
all right cool good oh
[Music]
well i'm dead thank you i like that that
was interesting
i mean there wasn't anything like super
unique and it didn't explain itself at
all but
hey in two weeks you know that's not bad
my first game jam that was pretty good
for your first game
that was nice i liked it a forgotten but
lingering past a knee i'm done reading
now
day one apparent hi this is linger uh
fascinating i hope to make good choices
while i play this game
ooh excellent choices if those magazines
are what i they are not
hey there i often love waking up and
getting a
personalized message first thing in the
morning thanks for staying in my
apartment
who are you i hope you enjoy your time
here sadly there's a really bad
snowstorm going on outside and you'll
have to stay locked in
but don't worry it will be fine sure
who are you how about you familiarize
yourself with the apartment
go inside every room and also check out
the living room
dining table and kitchen place is
wonderful
what the hell is wrong with you what the
hell is wrong with the
demon that wrote this letter who
who says anything that way
who says the horrible things that you
say yeah i'll check out every room yeah
welcome to my house
check out every little every room
all right that was useful
i turned the tv on i'm very happy about
that
time to check every room this is not my
luggage was someone else here recently
oh you know yeah
save energy and turn off the lights i'll
leave the tv on because
i'm an idiot a fire pit looks pretty
warm would love to have that right now
as
it is pretty cold it's okay i take joy
in pictures of
fires hello me i'm a ghost i'm a vampire
i'm a vampire wow
oh that's like that that that's that's
not right
that's not right well this mirror isn't
buggy but that one sure is
okay cool thank you
thank you thank you
i'm checking out every room
wow this looks like a cozy chess setup a
chessboard never understood this game
well i mean i don't like to play it but
at least i understand it
turn on phone turn off phone turn
on phone turn off phone turn on phone
turn off phone turn on phone turn off
phone
turn on phone off
well that was fun i'm glad i did that
this house really is amazing
it's a big apartment there's a big
apartment what is this supposed to be
why is there a bathroom with a jacuzzi
over here this evening
ain't even a bedroom that's what the
layout of this why is the laundry over
here what what is this is weird
it's a weird place
closet full of house cleaning tools yeah
okay still weird
but also it's clogged it's chuggalogging
the game is
chuggalogging
oh wait what the hell why did it get
dark
why is it now dark why why dark
oh i'm oh
i just had so much fun exploring the
house that i
lost track of time i'm awake again
wow this house is really something
well oh that's lights on okay
very strange a coffee machine
yeah uh-huh
snow is completely covering the window
uh-huh
it won't budge it's as if it was frozen
entirely righty ho
refrigerator we'll be getting some beer
later on to enjoy myself while the snow
storm patches
sure you will is there some kind of
secret that i'm supposed to
identify am i supposed to actually find
something here
oh do you hear the frequencies emitting
from the electronics turn on all
electronics in the apartment make sure
all electronics are
emitting frequencies for a couple
seconds it's very very rejuvenating
what do you mean you mean it's very very
rejuvenating
what do you mean rejuvenating
turn on the phone i don't like it i got
a bad feeling about it
it's time for day three i'm so
rejuvenated i'm so rejovenated
so rejoven nutted
all right now that you have experienced
the frequencies follow the next step to
become
one with them oh great turn off all the
lights in the apartment head to the
living room and turn on the tv then
stare at it to begin the process
this will only work if all the lights
are turned off the apartment must be
[ __ ] black
don't be scared trust the process ah
okay you know this apartment's weirdly
dark and in shadows as it is
but uh yeah i'll take your advice let's
turn off everything
save power you know it's just it's just
good for the environment
this feels real smart to do this feels
like big brain good boy decisions
okay that's pretty dark good thing i
trust the process
because if i did not be dead okay i
think that
with this and one more over there
okay stare at the tv for a bit
the process the process
i love the process i love the process i
love the process so much
i like the process the process is good
i'm just going to keep staring at this
until the process takes me there's the
process
i love that process you know the process
is
really nice that's really good
[Music]
you're doing good a friend will be
calling in a couple minutes make sure
you pick up the phone in the study room
and listen carefully it's only a matter
of time till she visits
until who visits okay
okay i'll just be waiting patiently by
this phone
or not it's quite a bop you got there
it's quite a bop
oh the process has affected this chair
ah okay you know i'm gonna go answer
that
i'll just go answer that i'll just go
answer that yeah i'll just answer
that yeah
yeah hello
you're gonna have to speak up
i really do
apparently it's day five now that put me
right to sleep
they really know how to sing a lullaby
oh
i can't move i'm awake who was that
who opened oh who opened the door
there's three things that don't belong
in this apartment search truly and try
turning them on
she's getting closer can you feel her
oh
oh yeah oh what is that where did this
come from
oh okay i guess i can't turn it on i
have no idea how to turn that on
that definitely doesn't belong here
someone out here
who's been opening doors oh it's been
opening doors
who why oh i can see now
oh
hello where did this come from
[Music]
oh
okay thank you
hello anyone seeing a weird ass old tv
in here
some broken and dilapidated and probably
shouldn't be in existence
anybody seen one of those is that chair
still on the ceiling oh good i was
hoping
was that it did i find it
where did this come from oh well i'm
passing out again
day six give it up for day six
everyone loves day six day six is my
favorite day
hello she lingers my eyes she took them
she doesn't like to be looked at for
long my eyes are somewhere in the house
don't let her get close man this house
is good
how's it lovely i love this house your
eyes are somewhere in the house
i don't want to know what that means i
don't i really don't want to know what
that means
yeah i'm not going to pay attention to
that that's probably nothing anybody
seen a pair of eyes
anybody see any eyes
oh you know about that well
for freaking frick okay
well that's the problem hey anybody seen
eyes
um anybody seen eyes anybody got some
somebody seen some eyes around here am i
seeing eyes in the
laundry i always lose my eyes and oh i
okay found an eye
well i got i i don't got eyes
hello peekaboo
oh hey
yep okay yeah okay there's the girl from
the ring who's just walking around the
apartment that's fine am i gonna be
trapped in this room what is the deal
are you there
oh well that's a problem i don't know
what to do about that she doesn't like
to be looked that long i don't know like
oh damn it damn it ah damn it
damn damn it you still there
hello
hello who i'm speaking i'm so sneaky i'm
so sneaky
i got the eyeballs
i didn't win i'm not quite sure how i
would have just been able to go to sleep
after uh knowing that she's just
wandering around dot dot dot
hello hello
hello
oh okay yeah i'm coming
oh oh hi
how are you you shuffled the snow
thank you you better come over here and
give me a big hug
or i'm gonna come to you hog trains pull
it
um oh
i mean should i be worried about that is
that something i should be worried about
is that a bad thing is this bad oh i
knew it
i knew it wasn't bad knew it unless
you're behind me
maybe there you back there nah i knew it
nothing that's what i thought
i can't make it out
oh well back i go then
[Music]
oh there you are hey hug train coming
into hug
station coming in
oh well
oh hey um listen you're doing a lot of
ring around the rosie here and uh you
just need to give me the hug
once you give me this hug then we're
gonna be cool hi there we go
that's what i'm talking about that's the
hug i needed
oh i'm back here oh i thought that would
have been it i thought that well
hey diddly ho
[Music]
that would have been terrifying if i
could have seen anything that was good i
liked that it was a bit of a slow burn
the objectives were a little nonsensical
it really was
just go a b collect x y
but the mood and the spookiness was real
good you know uh it was actually
oddly enough scarier before she even
appeared
it was much scarier before she ever
appeared but still
very good i think that was good very
good
[Music]
[Applause]
you